what's going on guys this is rob and um
let's talk about this eternals movie
um would i have given this movie a 59 on
rotten tomatoes
no
do i understand why some people did
yes
okay so so as always when it comes to
these things right uh one thing that i
want to make clear
the dislikes that i had for this movie
weren't really tied to the comics
there's a reason for that right so um
one of the things we talked about here
right like the eternals first appeared
in the 70s ever since the eternals
showed up in marvel comics the biggest
struggle marvel has had is getting
people to care about the eternals
because by and large they just seem
unnecessary
right the role of the eternals and
marvel comics is to safeguard humanity
from the deviants and whatever threats
may befall the earth from beyond the
stars right extraterrestrials different
things like that
but as time has progressed and as
humanity has grown more powerful in the
comics now you got stuff like the x-men
and x-factor and x-force and alpha
flight and omega-flight and big hero 6
and the avengers and the new avengers
and the mighty avengers and west coast
avengers and all kinds of stuff right
you got all kinds of of teams that exist
out there and that's to say nothing of
ultra powerful beings like hyperion and
the century or franklin richards or the
molecule man owen reese and just those
four guys their powers dwarf the powers
of the eternals themselves so by and
large there isn't a need for the
eternals to safeguard humanity from
anything because humanity can protect
itself and so ever since then no one's
really cared about the eternals because
no one's wrote a compelling story to
give people a reason to care about the
eternals so i didn't really go into this
film expecting this to basically pick up
and to correct all the mistakes that the
comics had made having said that the
movie had pluses and it had minuses just
like any movie so let's start with the
things that i loved about this so
overall just in terms of how the movie
looked not really focusing on the
character development or anything like
that but just the visual look of the
film it was gorgeous right the
soundtrack was fantastic the special
effects were mind-blowing i absolutely
loved it it just it was a visually
stunning film one of the things that i
loved the most about this and i was a
little uncertain about how it would
unfold the celestials right the
celestials
were enormous they were every bit as
imposing as you would expect them to be
right okay so let's say i'm irishm the
judge right just to give you guys
perspective let's say i'm irish and the
judge and i'm holding my hand out right
the eternals were like that tall in my
hand they were miniscule in comparison
to the size of the celestials which
really gets me excited about what like
galactus would look like in the mcu
right like imagine just a person who
looks like they're in a giant purple
suit who's just that big right it's just
it was it was it was crazy how imposing
they were one of the other things i
loved about this film was the deviants
they looked great oh my god they looked
phenomenal which makes sense one of the
things i didn't expect going into this
movie is for the deviants to look like
they do in the comics right where they
look like trolls or monsters or
something like that
honestly i don't even think that would
have been cool if it happened because i
felt like it would have made the movie
feel laughable right it would have it
would have felt goofy you see these kind
of trollish looking monsters that just
it would have just felt too nonsensical
even for a comic book film we know
that's one of the things the mcu does
they take things that we would
historically see as being sort of like
monster-ish looking and they kind of
make them a little more sleek a little
more modern and it works right it looks
really really awesome so i love the way
the deviants looked in this film a
couple of the other things that i loved
kind of rounding out this this bit of a
list i did love the emergence event that
was great and it was everything i was
hoping it would be right everything that
i was hoping it would be the motivation
behind why the emergence is happening
who it is that's emerging i was i was
super excited for that right i thought
it was really really awesome the funny
thing about this emergence thing though
is that if you're looking and if you're
really really paying attention
there's some big
impacts it has on potentially a land
mass
that exists between america and another
country
ruled by a guy
just saying
i'm just kidding no spoilers no no
spoilers for that part i'll let you guys
know when there are spoilers honestly uh
the emergence was great right it was
really really cool and it was it was
just it was
the the the intensity of that right like
the significance of that what happens if
the emergence actually takes place it
was phenomenal so i absolutely love that
and the final thing that i loved about
this movie was actually a character dane
whitman i loved dane whitman and i
didn't think i would i've never cared
about dane whitman there's never been an
instance in the history of my life when
i've been reading marvel comics like oh
my god cool a new black knight series is
coming out i can't wait to get to the
store and read that that's never
happened
ever over the course of my life i have
never ever ever been excited about the
black knight i'm excited as hell to see
what they do with this character in the
mcu i am super hyped about that i think
part of it's because it's just kit
harrington and i don't know what it is
man but that guy just
he's just got it man like it's just i
don't i don't know i love him as an
actor i think he's phenomenal i think
the the the kind of character
development and just the way he existed
in the mcu the kind of questions he
asked in a lot of ways he was a stand-in
for us uh i think it was great i think
it was really really cool and i'm
excited to see where he goes now having
said that
let's focus on the stuff that i didn't
like about this
and this portion will probably include
some spoilers
so first things first the film was like
75 dialogue you can't go into this movie
expecting it to be like your standard
marvel cinematic universe movie where
there's like a lot of action a lot of
fight scenes that happen over the course
of the film you did have some fight
scenes but none of them felt like they
mattered none of them felt like they
were relevant we'll talk about that here
in a second the movie was mostly
dialogue in flashbacks now this is the
most disappointing thing about the
flashbacks that they had the flashbacks
did deal with the eternals themselves
but because 75 of the movie was
basically dialogue and it was the
eternals going and finding other
eternals the flashbacks you get are
basically held strictly to those
eternals now that in and of itself is
not a bad thing the problem is there's
nothing that tells you that is in the
mcu outside of a reference to the blip
that's it that's that's the only thing
you get and i felt like these were some
huge missed opportunities and here's the
reason why so this is one of those
spoiler parts that what you ended up
getting was this point whereby the
eternals basically broke apart right
they split apart and they just went out
into the world and just lived their
lives and so the question that most all
of us were left asking and the question
that we wanted to have answered in this
movie is what were the eternals doing
during some of the seminal moments or
seminal points in the marvel cinematic
universe the invasion of new york when
thanos blinked out half the life in the
universe now i do agree that the movie
didn't need to focus on thanos if they
had brought thanos in they had given us
the backstory of thanos it would have
turned into a thano-centric film we can
all admit that because thanos is so
popular in the mcu so i understand their
desire to avoid that having said that it
didn't mean that you had to show thanos
that with the eternals going out into
the world and living for thousands of
years they formed a lot of interpersonal
relationships they had lovers and they
had co-workers and they had friends and
possibly even had some measure of family
right like they married into a family
because eternals can't necessarily
procreate they can't do it in the comics
and they can't do it here so it makes
sense they wouldn't really be able to
have kids of their own but they made a
life for themselves they developed
interpersonal relationships and i felt
like it would have really added to the
gravity of both the character
development and their role in the mcu if
they had to watch people they care about
get dusted and then deal with the
aftermath of that even if you never see
thanos right a really good example of
this is one division right like monica
rambo popped back up and as she's
running through the hospital people are
just reappearing right you never see
thanos but you understand what's going
on that people are coming back after the
incredible hulk snapped his fingers and
brought everybody back and then that's
basically it right so you get that kind
of moment give us the other half of that
right people disappearing that these
eternals out there are losing friends
that they've had for like 20 years of
their life just different things along
those lines right give us those little
tidbits there we didn't really get that
one of the things that i thought would
have been really cool is that because
the eternals were essentially just
masquerading as humans they obviously
wouldn't necessarily use their powers
and they didn't really use their powers
unless they absolutely had to and if
they did they largely used them in
secret meaning nobody in the superhero
community was aware of the fact that
they existed so it would have been
really really cool to see a scene if
like in the first avengers movie one of
the eternals was in new york and there
was some giant chunk of a building that
was falling down we know the eternal
would survive it the eternal knows they
would survive it although they don't
really see it landing down on them and
in the midst of all that iron man just
flies in saves them and then just flies
away having no idea of what it is that
he's doing he's just saving a regular
person as far as he's concerned but in
reality he's saving an eternal that
didn't need to be saved just one of
those instances where the eternals and
superheroes in the mcu cross paths not
really knowing it but the eternals given
their longevity know who iron man is
right you could also do things like
fostus who was the kind of like
scientific technological guy of the
eternals worked for shield or he was one
of the guys who worked in stark
industries or something like that not
because he had to but because he wanted
to and he loves technology things along
those lines somebody like druid was
responsible for basically leading the
government or having a hand in the
government that was just terrorizing and
destroying people's lives in sokovia and
that's what led to people like wanda and
pietro overthrowing the sokovian
government just things along those lines
right just those small little moments
little tidbits that would have made the
movie feel like it was in the mcu
because the reality is it doesn't the
movie does not feel like it's in the
marvel cinematic universe the only
reason you know it's in the marvel
cinematic universe is because it's a
marvel film but if marvel took their
name off of it and released this movie
you would never know you would have no
idea that is part of the marvel
cinematic universe and i think that's an
issue now this was compounded by kind of
a point that we made earlier that there
weren't a whole lot of action scenes and
the action scenes they did have didn't
really seem to serve a purpose that's
one of the bigger issues right the
deviants are in there but the deviants
feel more of a background thing so you
do see scenarios where the eternals
fight the deviants but it feels like
it's just something they're doing while
the may well the bigger plot is going on
it doesn't feel any different than like
iron man going into a store and buying a
coke it's kind of what it feels like you
know what i mean where it's just like a
thing they happen to be doing at the
time there's no real significance there
right it doesn't feel like it's a major
point in the movie or that it has any
real bearing on the movie and in fact
the deviants themselves kind of felt
like they were just crammed into the
movie for the purpose of giving us kind
of an interim villain until we actually
get to the main plot the main goal of
the film and i feel like that just sort
of takes away from it all this is
particularly important because once you
get to the final fight between crow and
the the eternals themselves it doesn't
matter right it doesn't like the outcome
of the fight just feels completely and
totally irrelevant like okay cool
whatever you know and then that's it
right so it's just kind of like i mean i
i mean what was the point of having the
deviants in the movie like that i guess
the deviants are there to justify the
existence of the eternals but at that
point if the deviants existing is to
simply just justify the existence of the
eternals and why they're there then just
remove the deviance and the
justification and give the eternals a
different justification for being there
and then just call it a day the other
part of this and this is kind of the
last um i guess complaint that i have
here is that the eternals themselves
felt boring they felt like they don't
matter um i feel like in six months if i
was on a comic book reader in six months
i would have forgotten the names of the
eternals or i'd be mispronouncing them
so instead of calling her athena i'd be
calling her athena or something like
that right they they are largely
forgettable right they just don't really
feel like they matter there was no point
where i came out of this movie and i was
like oh my god dude those characters are
so cool i really hope disney plus gives
us a series on like cersei or athena or
icarus or or like sprite or fostos or
druid or any of those guys i really hope
we get that there was no part about this
that was like man these are great i
can't wait to see what the future holds
for the eternals didn't feel that at all
right i walked out and i was just like i
mean if they had killed off all the
eternals at the end of the movie it
would probably have the same feeling be
like okay so like it's a movie that
exists and i guess it's in the mcu and
so people did some things you know and
and you know i basically walked out of
the movie with this kind of feeling like
okay so like there were some people with
some powers and they did some things and
they fought people and we're here now
and so now we're leaving right and
that's it and it was just kind of like
all right
right it's just the the characters you
don't really have a reason to feel bad
for them you don't really have a reason
to to root for them or to hope they
succeed and the mcu is largely based on
that right spider-man for example is a
kid who's trying to be a superhero your
desire to root for spider-man is really
more predicated on just your knowledge
of spider-man than it is the actual plot
film itself but if you look at somebody
like iron man right he was a weapons
manufacturer that was trying to turn his
life around so you can root for him
right steve rogers captain america was a
guy out of time who seemingly lost
everything so you were hoping he could
make it in the modern era it was things
like that right thor was looking to
redeem himself with the eternals this is
kind of like i mean
there's no motivation to root for these
guys there's no there's nothing to be
like man i hope they really come out on
top because if they don't man imagine
the catastrophe your desire to see the
eternal succeed is because you don't
want to see the earth destroyed but it's
not really in relation to the eternals
themselves there's nothing about
cersei's story or fostos's story or
icarus story or anybody's story where
you want to see them succeed because of
some personal struggle they've had to
overcome that gives you an ability to
relate to them right so that lacks in
its entirety they're just characters who
are there and are doing things and then
it goes on for about two hours and then
the movie ends and the day's saved done
and done now having said that the cool
thing about this movie is the stage that
it sets for the future of the mcu so
there's a few big things spoilers here
right there's a few big things to know
one uh over the course of the movie it's
basically revealed the eternals on earth
are not the only eternals that exist in
the universe we know that from the
comics right we know that in the comics
that you had eternals on earth you had
uranus and you had kronos they got into
a civil war uranus basically lost he
took off into space eventually settled
on titan everybody wiped themselves out
except for a chick named sui-san there
was a second civil war among the
eternals this guy alars left went to
titan started banging suicide and they
had two sons thanos and eros so eros
shows up in a post-credits scene in this
movie as does pip the troll who's played
by pat and oswald which is amazing
i need to get the kind of connections
patton aswald has man because i would
love to just like have like a voiceover
role in the mcu or something like that i
don't know what it is man but that guy
he's everywhere man and it's awesome to
see but put the trolls there eros is
there now this is significant because of
the nature of the eternal so again more
of a spoiler here you end up finding out
that the turtles were basically built
that the the celestials initially built
the deviants the deviants were the ones
who were basically supposed to and make
it possible for planets to serve the
purpose of allowing celestials to
deposit their eggs in them to clear out
any predators and allow life to thrive
so that that life could feed the
celestial egg and when the celestial leg
was ready it would emerge right it would
basically destroy the planet and emerge
out into the universe essentially the
origin of how celestials are made in
earth x is basically what it is and so
the problem here is that the deviants
not only wiped out the predators on the
planet they also started consuming the
prey and so the celestials looked to
correct this because they there were
just too many deviants to destroy i
guess they looked to correct this and
they created the eternals to destroy
deviance and so the eternals end up
learning their true purpose the the
thing about eros here is that it seems
to establish this idea that a lot of
other eternals out there actually
learned the true role they learned the
truth of their creation at the hands of
the celestials and they defected they
broke off and they did their own thing
so i'm excited to see how that impacts
the future of the marvel cinematic
universe i think that's really really
cool the the the next thing that you get
is kind of the post like the actual post
credits scene because the hero scene is
more of a mid credit scene the post post
credit scene is basically
dane whitman going to get the ebony
blade this was kind of a major issue
when it came to his character is because
there's this offhanded remark by cersei
or this kind of statement she makes in
the aftermath of the realization that
they don't seem to be able to stop the
emergence that she in turn tells him you
should go make amends with your uncle
and it's like okay cool whatever like
there's not really a whole lot of
information given there because
literally kid harrington appears as a
total of like 20 minutes over the course
of the movie so you don't really get the
significance or the impact of that
unless you're familiar with the
character but dane whitman is descended
from sir percy of scandia he was the
black knight for king arthur and the
knights of the round table now at a time
when king arthur was basically being
attacked and was ultimately defeated by
his brother mordred that merlin created
the ebony blade as a means to defeat the
forces of mordred the problem with this
is the ebony blade has a curse that a
person who wields it will ultimately be
corrupted by it the stronger they become
right their bloodlust will basically
become uncontrollable and they'll be a
slave to the sword and so if you wield
it long enough it'll essentially destroy
you now we don't really know if that
curse is an actual thing in the mcu all
we know in the post-post credits scene
is dane whitman goes to reach for the
sword
okay so i'm standing outside petsmart
right now and uh we're taking star in
there so we can keep an eye on it while
we go to
denver because we can't take it with us
we're going to the museum but the
important thing is this uh apparently
chloe zhao did an interview with fandom
and she revealed that the voice at the
end of the movie that was talking to
dame whitman was blade
rehearsal ollie that's crazy i don't
know how that's going to affect
everything but
that's pretty boss uh
yeah man so i felt like i would just
kind of add that in here right just sort
of tell you guys that's apparently
what's going on anyway but overall when
it comes to this movie it's it's okay
right it's it's not a bad movie uh
apparently chloe zhao had help from
dennis villeneuve making this movie
dennis villeneuve if you don't know he's
the one that made the newer dune film if
she did get help it shows because the
movie is very very slow it looks
beautiful and the hipsters and the old
people will say that it's art but it
doesn't really feel like an mcu movie
that's not a bad thing because the mcu
formula was kind of growing stale but
while changing the mcu formula i think
is a great idea doing it in such a way
to where the movie feels boring because
it's like 75 dialogue that's a problem
that's an issue right so again you know
the movie i don't think it was worth i
don't think it deserved 59 on rotten
tomatoes but i wouldn't give it anything
near the 90s i'd give it mid 70s at best
and just kind of call it a day so with
that being said guys let me know what
you think down in the comments section
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace